While Huawei and ZTE have been rightly targeted
by the US government for their security risks,
another highly concerning Chinese tech company
has made considerable inroads in American homes
and businesses. Tuya is the world's leading
company in the internet of things, or IOT,
sector. Tuya's technologies power more than 100
million smart devices around the world, including
consumer products, surveillance equipment, and
manufacturing and supply chain applications.
One cyber security firm's investigation found that
Tuya-powered devices may be funneling sensitive
data to Beijing. Chinese law requires Tuya to
give its data to the Chinese government without
reporting this disclosure. Conceivably the PRC
could also use Tuya's vast reach to manipulate or
hack critical American infrastructure, imperiling
large swaths of our just-in-time economy.
There are ready alternatives to Tuya in America
and other trusted countries. It's time to cut
off the unnecessary risk that Tuya poses, and bar
the company from operating in the United States.
What do you think? Should the US government more
aggressively scrutinize Chinese tech companies?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.